die schwerelosigkeit dem weltraum hat
massive auswirkungen auf unser gehirn
das ist das ergebnis einer neuen studie
und damit es auch endlich geklärt warum
ein längerer aufenthalt im weltall das
sehvermögen deutlich beeinträchtigt sind
längere reisen in den weltraum also
unmöglich klick zum science fiction
hier gibt's täglich spannende
wissenschafts videos abonniert den kanal
nur dann verpasst ihr nichts herzlich
willkommen der aufenthalt im weltraum
ist eine tortur ergreift die gesundheit
des menschen an an allen ecken und enden
und es ist fraglich ob der mensch
überhaupt einen längeren aufenthalt im
weltraum überleben würde und eine neue
studie zu veränderungen im gehirn nährt
diese erkenntnis grundsätzlich fängt das
problem schon mit der generellen
dekoration an pro monat verlieren
menschen im weltraum 1,5 prozent ihrer
knochenmasse und training wie es
alexander gerst absolviert hat um diese
degeneration zu verlangsamen hat einen
extrem unangenehmen nebeneffekt fieber
die körpertemperatur von weltraum
fahrerinnen und fahrern liegt im
ruhezustand rund ein grad über dem
normalwert der auf der erde gilt körper
werden im weltraum über etwa zweieinhalb
monate lang immer wärmer dann etwa
pendelt sich die temperatur bei etwa 38
grad ein
und das könnte fatale folgen haben
messungen zeigen dass die
körpertemperatur der astronautinnen und
astronauten sogar oft auf mehr als 40
grad ansteigt eine studie geht davon aus
dass dieses ständige weltraum fieber von
den umständen dort herbeigeführt wird
der körper kann in der schwerelosigkeit
nur schwer seine überschüssige hitze
loswerden und selbst wenn diese
verdampft weniger als auf der erde und
wird so schlechter abtransportiert und
das ist nur ein aspekt auch die
sehfähigkeit nimmt im weltall ab das ist
fatal
70 prozent der astronauten und
astronautinnen über 50 die ein halbes
jahr auf der iss der internationalen
raumstation waren klagen über
sehprobleme brüllen mussten nach dem
aufenthalt angepasst werden
und wer keine brille hatte bekam jetzt
eine und jetzt sagt eine neue studie
die ursache dafür ist fatal bei der
studie wurden elf raum fahrer und
fahrerinnen untersucht sie waren
zwischen 2014 und 2018 für einige zeit
an bord der internationalen raumstation
iss
vor dem aufenthalt im all wurde ein
hirnscan gemacht zehn tage nach der
rückkehr und sieben monate später auch
als vergleich gab es noch den scans von
menschen die die erde nicht verlassen
hatten die ergebnisse sind ehrlich
gesagt ernüchternd der aufenthalt auf
der iss hatte massive auswirkungen auf
das gehirn die hirn ventrikel hohlräume
im gehirn die mit wasser gefüllt sind
vergrößerten sich im schnitt um zwölf
prozent bei den seiten wenn trittin
waren es sogar 13 prozent und hier
konnte ein zusammenhang zwischen dieser
vergrößerung und der verschlechterung
des sehvermögens nachgewiesen werden das
ist natürlich fatal
zum einen ist es natürlich bedenklich
dass die gesundheit nach einem
aufenthalt im all
nachhaltig beeinträchtigt wird und zudem
ist die frage was passiert bei längeren
aufenthalten wie einen flug zum mars
denen sich die ventrikel weiter aus
welche weiteren schäden richten sie dann
an
beim aktuellen stand ist es ein kaum zu
kalkulierendes risiko eine reise zum
mars könnte man so nicht riskieren die
besatzung könnte währenddessen solche
schäden erleiden dass sie nicht mehr in
der lage wäre die mission zu ende zu
bringen eine absolute katastrophe
einen trost gibt es allerdings diese
ausdehnung der band rieke geht auf der
erde scheinbar langsam wieder zurück
nach sieben monaten auf dem boden war
die ausdehnung wieder um die hälfte
zurückgegangen die gesundheit im
weltraum scheint ein wirklich komplexes
problem zu sein
nach dem jetzigen stand könnte sie
längere raumflüge generell verhindern
für eine mars-mission müssten wir dieses
problem und auch die anderen
herausforderungen unbedingt lösen damit
die reise nicht in einer katastrophe
endet wie einsteins gehirn gestohlen
wurde eine absolut unglaubliche story
anklicken anschauen und astro comics tv
abonnieren bis dann bleibt dran